[Music]
n
just
[Music]
walking down the street and you hear
that heavy be can help good walk your
feet down all the way till you meet
people laughing and dancing all night
long and through the flashing see the B
playing song and you want to see the
world through different eyes just fought
tonight and you're hoping that this
night will never end you'll surrender if
you feel the music fold around you and
pull you into the light it takes away
all strain and stress and turns it into
light
just walk your feet down
he
[Music]
to the be if you can take it goe let
your hands in the
ceiling move to the Beet if you can't
help it it will control you and take you
away just for tonight what do you mean
by sure they're not going to take it off
more than once are
[Music]
they just for tonight
is everything's absolutely Splendid
walking down the street and you hear
that heavy help walk your feet down all
the way to me people laughing and
dancing all night long and through the
flashing lights see the playing s want
to see the world through different eyes
just fought tonight and you're hoping
that this night one night W end you'll
surrender if you feel the music fold
around and pull you into the life for
how it takes away all strain and stress
and turns it into light just for
tonight walk your feet down
a
w